weltweiter schlag gegen schwerkriminelle
mit angeblich abhörsicheren handys
täuschen ermittler monatelang
gangsterbanden hunderte verdächtige
werden festgenommen
keine kinderrechte ins grundgesetz die
verhandlungen der bundestagsparteien
endet ohne einigung im streit und
algenplage im marmarameer vor der
türkischen küste ersticken pflanzen und
tiere an dicken schwein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem dienstag
an meiner seite ist für den sport
norbert lehmann als sogenannter von mir
wir beginnen mit einem der größten
erfolge gegen das internationale
verbrechen den es je gab
gleichzeitige razzien in 16 ländern bei
denen mafiosi genauso ins netz gingen
wie mitglieder von drogen syndikaten
insgesamt konnten die ermittler 800
verdächtige festnehmen und 48 millionen
dollar beschlagnahmen
allein wie die kriminellen auf logan
klingt wie ein thriller
18 monate lang hörten und lasen die
fahnder heimlich bei den gesprächen der
täter mit weil die sich mit ihren
präparierten handys zu sicher fühlten
stefan schlosser hunderte male klickten
die handschellen über 30 tonnen drogen
zahlreiche waffen und bargeld in
zweistelliger millionenhöhe wurden
sichergestellt ein teil der bilanz der
weltweiten aktion gegen die organisierte
kriminalität unter führung des
amerikanischen fbi ist es gelungen in
verschlüsselte kommunikationswege in
sogenannte crypto netzwerke einzudringen
und so die absprachen der verbrecher zu
überwachen genannt operation trojaner
schild der erfolg der operation trojaner
schild ist das ergebnis gewaltiger
innovation einsatzbereitschaft und
beispielloser internationaler
zusammenarbeit die ergebnisse sind
atemberaubend für die operation haben
die ermittler eine eigene angeblich
abhörsichere nachrichten app entwickelt
und mit hilfe von informanten unter rund
300 kriminellen organisationen mehr als
100 ländern verbreitet 12.000 dieser
handys waren im umlauf
so konnten die behörden nachrichten
chats über viele monate in echtzeit mit
lesen sie sprachen über drogen gewalt
gegenseitige anschläge über unschuldige
die ermordet werden sollten die ganze
bandbreite
es war offenbar nichts dabei zu sagen
ich brauche 1000 kilos zu dem preis der
sie haben nicht versucht das hinter
irgendwelchen code wörtern zu verstecken
die mafia asiatische syndikate
kriminelle rockerbanden sie alle
lieferten den ermittlern ungewollt
einblicke in ihre geschäfte bis die
strafverfolger jetzt zuschlugen auch in
deutschland wurden über 70 personen
festgenommen vor allem im zusammenhang
mit drogenhandel die ganze tragweite
dieses ermittlungserfolg es lässt sich
aber noch gar nicht absehen was ist das
besondere an diesen neben der ja die
sicherheitsbehörden haben ja hier etwas
aufgestellt was sie im fachjargon einen
honigtopf nennen also ein honigtopf von
dem die bienen um im bild zu bleiben
also die kriminellen magisch angezogen
werden und es ist der grösste honigtopf
der letzten jahrzehnte
dafür haben die sicherheitsbehörden
selber gesorgt sie haben nämlich in den
vergangenen zwei jahren einige andere
plattformen dicht gemacht mit denen man
ebenfalls verschlüsselt kommunizieren
konnte so dass die verbrecherbanden
gezwungen waren auf diese neue app
auszuweichen
ohne zu wissen dass das fbi dahinter
steckte und die wirkung reicht jetzt
eben weit über die razzien über die
festnahmen
unter den festgenommenen sind auch
einige hochrangige bandenmitglieder also
das reicht weit über das hinaus weil
eben nun misstrauen herrscht die
kriminellen müssen damit rechnen dass
egal welche verschlüsselte plattform sie
in zukunft nutzen möglicherweise die
sicherheitsbehörden mit höheren und auf
dieses misstrauen dass da jetzt
verbreitet wurde bei den
verbrecherbanden darauf ist das fbi hier
in den usa oder auch seine partner
partner rund um den globus besonders
stolz informationen live aus washington
danke schön herr matti wissen mehr zum
großen bruder ermittler in einem zdf-
heute live gleich um 19 uhr 30 wir reden
über die razzien mit experten und wenn
sie wollen diskutieren sie mit entweder
in der zdf- heute- app oder auf unseren
social media kanälen
kinder sind besonders schutzbedürftig so
weit ist sich die große koalition einig
doch der versuch kinderrechte im
grundgesetz zu verankern ist jetzt erst
mal gescheitert
dabei hatten union und spd das bereits
im koalitionsvertrag verabredet erst im
januar dieses jahres stand dann ein text
so sollte er beginnen die
verfassungsmäßigen rechte der kinder
einschließlich ihres rechts auf
entwicklung zu eigenverantwortlichen
persönlichkeiten sind zu achten und zu
schützen
woran es hing andrea maurer es waren die
kinder die wohl besonders beeinträchtigt
waren in dieser pandemie einen
besonderen schutz durch das grundgesetz
bekommen sie auch in zukunft nicht das
koalitionsziel kinderrechte in der
verfassung zu verankern ist gescheitert
teilt die familien und justizministerium
mit wir hatten jetzt die historische
chance die kinderrechte sichtbar zu
machen in unserer werteordnung in
unserem grundgesetz und ich bedauere es
zutiefst dass der streit über
detailfragen eine einigung am ende bei
diesem so wichtigen vorhaben verhindert
hat im januar hatte das kabinett einen
gesetzentwurf auf den weg gebracht
unions und spd fraktion stritten danach
weiter für die grundgesetzänderung wäre
eine zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag
und bundesrat nötig gewesen
fdp und grüne verhandelten mit einigen
konnten sich am ende alle nicht das
bedaure ich sehr weil wir uns wirklich
sehr viel mühe gegeben haben einen
kompromiss zu finden
in den verhandlungen mit fdp und grünen
auch auf die zuzugehen und ihnen nicht
nur den regierungsvorschlag vor die nase
zu halten es hat natürlich in erster
linie an der union gelegen hatte aber
auch an der ministerin gelegen die es
nicht vermocht hat die mehrheiten
zustande zu bekommen
ich kann nur sagen an uns als nicht
gelegen kinderschutzorganisationen sind
enttäuscht das ist eine deprimierende
erfahrung an ein deprimierendes signal
an die familien und kinder in
deutschland dass es nicht gelungen ist
gute kinderrechte echte kinderrechte ins
grundgesetz zu bringen
kinderrechte die den schutz die
förderung die beteiligung den kindern
sichern
es wird in dieser legislaturperiode wohl
keine weiteren verhandlungen geben
theo koll in berlin was sagt dieses
scheitern über den zustand der regierung
aus man kennt diesen zustand der von
amerikanischen präsidenten kurz vor in
die rahmen zeiten gelten sie als
sogenannte lame duck als lahme ente auch
die große koalition ist jetzt in diesem
zustand dass sie kurz vor ende ihrer
amtszeit nicht mehr fliegt dafür aber
beide flügel heftig schlagen auch und
vor allem aufeinander ein das scheitern
der vereinbarung zu den kinderrechten im
grundgesetz reiht sich ein in eine immer
länger werdende liste von aufgekündigten
kompromissen die aufteilung der co2
kosten beispielsweise auf mieter und
vermieter war ja auch eines der jüngeren
beispiele teile der unionsfraktion
ärgern sich seit langem über die aus
ihrer sicht zu weitgehenden
zugeständnisse an die spd und die spd
wiederum ist zunehmend regierung und
opposition und zwar gleichzeitig kurz
zusammengefasst es ist weigert
dankeschön bei den türken bis 68
arbeiten das hat ein beratergremium des
wirtschaftsministeriums vorgeschlagen
anders sei die rente langfristig schwer
zu finanzieren meinen die experten
auch künftige rentenerhöhungen sollten
begrenzt werden
bei spd linken und gewerkschaften kam
das nicht gut an sie lehnten eine
erhöhung des rentenalters strikt ab aber
auch wirtschaftsminister altmaier will
an der rente mit 67 festhalten
mehr dazu hat patrizia wiedemeier
spätestens ab 2025 wenn die sogenannten
baby boomer in den ruhestand gehen werde
es ein finanzierungs schock geben
gewaltige probleme der staatlichen
rentenkasse länger arbeiten um die
kassen zu entlasten flexibel zwischen 63
und 68 in rente gehen vor 68 jedoch mit
abschlägen fordert daher den
wissenschaftliche beirat des
wirtschaftsministeriums beliebig später
es sind nicht nur die baby boomer auch
teure renten beschlüsse der groko
treiben die kosten der alterssicherung
langfristig in die höhe
zum beispiel die neue grundrente die
angleichung der ost an die westrenten
die erhöhung der mütter renten und die
abschlagsfreie rente mit 63
trotz der hohen kosten in berlin heute
parteiübergreifende ablehnung einer
rente mit 68
die stabilität der rentenversicherung
die entscheidet sich in den nächsten
jahren am arbeitsmarkt wenn wir schaffen
möglichst viele menschen ordentliche
arbeit zu bringen und in ordentliche
arbeit zu halten und angemessenen lohn
und gehaltsentwicklung da ist dann ist
die rentenversicherung auch stabil und
leistungsfähig kritik auch von der
opposition
es gibt menschen die können und wollen
nicht so lange arbeiten und es gibt
menschen die wollen auch gerne länger
arbeiten
deshalb brauchen wir insgesamt ein neues
denken in der rente die rente mit 68 ist
kein thema das mit uns in irgendeiner
weise zu machen ist das thema rente es
ist ein dauerbrenner
die nächste bundesregierung wird um eine
weitreichende reform wohl nicht
herumkommen
nach der wahl in sachsen anhalt wird es
wohl keine neuauflage der kenya
koalition aus cdu spd und grünen geben
denn die grünen haben erklärt sie seien
zwar bereit mit zu regieren aber nur
wenn sie in einer koalition auch
gebraucht würden
cdu und spd hätten aber auch ohne sie
eine mehrheit im parlament
der sächsische verfassungsschutz hat
illegal informationen über
landtagsabgeordnete gesammelt und
gespeichert zu diesem ergebnis kommt ein
bericht der parlamentarischen
kontrollkommission betroffen war neben
politikern von grünen und linken auch
der stellvertretende ministerpräsident
und spd chef martin dulig über ihn
wurden etwa informationen über die
teilnahme an demonstrationen oder
facebook eindrücke gesammelt
du legst sprach von einem
ungeheuerlichen vorgang der
verfassungsschutz räumte fehler ein
die korona lage in deutschland entspannt
sich weiter nach angaben des robert koch
instituts gibt es inzwischen erste
landkreise in denen es seit sieben tagen
gar keine neuen fälle mehr gibt
friesland und goslar in niedersachsen
bundesweit wurden innerhalb eines tages
1204 neuinfektionen registriert das sind
581 weniger als vor einer woche
binnen 24 stunden gab
150 neue todesfälle die sieben tage
incidents liegt bundesweit bei 22,9 die
niedrigen zahlen führen in verschiedenen
bundesländern zu weiteren lockerungen in
mecklenburg vorpommern müssen schüler im
unterricht keine masken mehr tragen und
auch in sachsens schulen fällt die
masken pflicht weg voraussetzung eine
inzidenz von unter 35 die testpflicht
dagegen bleibt bestehen
neues kapitel im fall des umstrittenen
kölner kardinal woelki heute haben die
beiden gesandten des papstes ihre arbeit
aufgenommen
sie sollen mögliche fehler des kardinals
im umgang mit missbrauchsfällen
untersuchen und vertuschungs vorwürfe
klären aus köln peter dimmer
sie waren die ersten gesprächspartner
der visitatoren heute opfer sexuellen
missbrauchs durch kirchliche
würdenträger
die taten liegen jahrzehnte zurück so
eine aufmerksamkeit haben sie bisher in
köln vermisst
ich bin erstaunt ich bin in köln in
kirchlichem zusammenhang und mir wurde
zugehört das ist mir völlig egal wer auf
dem stuhl des erzbischofs von köln sitzt
was ich möchte ist echte verträgt das
vertrauen echte transparenz echter
dialog der stockholmer kardinal aurelius
links und der rotterdamer bischof an den
hände recht soll nun als päpstliche
gesandte ergründen ob der umgang des
erzbischofs woelki mit dem missbrauchs
komplex fehlerhaft war oder nicht
wirklich wird unter anderem vorgeworfen
priester im amt belassen und auch
befördert zu haben obwohl es deutliche
hinweise auf pädophilie gab
missbrauchsopfer fühlen sich von ihm
auch nicht ernst genommen und zu könnte
seine jüngste video botschaft auf
gemischte gefühle treffen hier in
unserem erzbistum werde ich als bischof
alles dafür tun dass die aufarbeitung
weitergeht und ich und wir dem auftrag
jesu gerecht werden die schwachen zu
schützen und missbrauch zu verhindern
kardinal woelki war in einem
rechtsgutachten entlastet worden
doch der bericht der visitatoren könnte
beim papst schwer wiegen wegen tausender
kirchenaustritte und auch kirchlichen
widerstand sehen können
denn der klerus also die leitenden
priesters aber auch die gläubigen dem
general signalisieren wir wollen nicht
mehr mit ihr zusammenarbeiten
sie haben das vertrauen in dich komplett
verloren das ist dann immer für rom die
rote grenze überschritten ist und wo sie
einschreiten der punkt ist erreicht wie
der papst lässt sich entscheiden wird
ist völlig unklar
die visitatoren werden weitere gespräche
führen und dann einen vertraulichen
bericht an den vatikan schicken streiks
mitten in der hauptreisezeit könnte es
bei der bahn geben denn die
tarifverhandlungen mit der
lokführergewerkschaft gdl sind
gescheitert die gewerkschaft hat
arbeitskampfmaßnahmen angekündigt bisher
aber keinen termin dafür genannt er gilt
als einer der hauptverantwortlichen für
die gräueltaten im bosnienkrieg ex
general ratko mladic das un
kriegsverbrechertribunal hatte ihn 2017
zu lebenslanger haft verurteilt auch für
den völkermord in srebrenica vor fast 26
jahren
heute hat das gericht das urteil gegen
den ehemaligen armeechef in letzter
instanz bestätigt unter seiner führung
hatten serbische truppen 1995 mehr als
8000 bosnisch muslimische männer und
jungen ermordet
heute am welttag der ozeane warnen die
vereinten nationen vereinten nationen
sind die meere krank dann ist auch das
leben an land gefährdet und die meere
sind in einem schlechten zustand
verseucht durch müll und abwasser zudem
werden sie immer wärmer besonders
schlimm ist es gerade vor der türkischen
küste im marmarameer dass die igs mit
dem schwarzen meer verbindet dort hat
sich eine dicke lebensfeindliche
schleimschicht gebildet jörg brase
berichtet eine schleimige masse war butt
am ufer des marmarameeres verklebt tower
und netze
der sogenannte meeres schleim ist das
ausscheidungs produkt von phytoplankton
mikroskopisch kleinen algen nach einiger
zeit sinkt das gewebe auf den
meeresgrund und erstickt alles leben
darunter
umweltschützer sind alarmiert wenn alle
meeres pflanzen und tiere dadurch
absterben und damit auch im meer der
sauerstoff entzogen wird ist das extrem
schädlich und was ist der grund die
verschmutzung des meeres in der region
leben rund 25 millionen menschen
städte wie bußer coach eli und istanbul
punkten nur unzureichend geklärte
industrie und haus abwässer ins meer
das fördert dem sich durch den
klimawandel erwärmenden wasser das
algenwachstum weil die aufregung um die
schleim klage immer größer wurde
erklärte der türkische präsident das
problem am wochenende zur chefsache
meine sorge ist dass sich der schleim
auch im schwarzen meer ausbreitet und
von dort noch zusätzlich ins meer
gelangt dann wird der schaden immens
sein
daher müssen wir jetzt ohne verzögerung
die nötigen schritte unternehmen zurzeit
rückt man dem problem mit schwimmenden
räummaschinen zu leibe
das allein aber werde kaum reichen
kritisieren umweltschützer
das marmarameer ruft um hilfe
die rufe haben wir lange nicht gehört
jetzt zeigt uns dass mehr in welcher
note sich befindet nun will die
regierung die kläranlagen sanieren und
die wasserverschmutzung im marmarameer
bekämpfen dafür ist es tatsächlich
höchste zeit
und jetzt fußballer uns um 721 der
dfb-elf gestern abend im letzten
testspiel vor der em lettland allerdings
nur ein zweitklassiger gegner in einer
woche aber geht es gegen weltmeister
frankreich das dfb team jedenfalls nach
dem tor spektakel in bester laune
flughafen nürnberg vor einer guten
stunde der himmel über franken hätte
sich durchaus etwas einladender
präsentieren können zur ankunft der
prominenten reisegruppe nächsten
dienstag der em auftakt gegen frankreich
gestern abend ein letzter test zum teil
recht ansehnlich die letten allerdings
nur nummer 138 der weltrangliste kein
wirklicher gradmesser
natürlich ist lettland nicht frankreich
da braucht man nicht reden aber wir
haben das was wir im training erarbeitet
haben umsetzen können im spiel im
quartier in herzogenaurach wohnen
jeweils vier spieler zusammen in einem
kleinen haus teambuilding als basis für
den erfolg und die aussichten für die
kommenden tage sind auch ganz passabel
zwei jahre hatte er unter dem namen
silas war marica für den bundesligisten
vfb stuttgart gespielt jetzt hat der
verein mitgeteilt die identität des
kongolesen war gefälscht er soll opfer
der machenschaften seines ehemaligen
spielervermittlers sein
der dfb-kontrollausschuss überprüft nun
ob dem 22 jährigen eine neue spiel
erlaubnis erteilt werden kann
bei der hockey em in amsterdam hat die
deutsche männer national mannschaft das
halbfinale erreicht im spektakulären
letzten gruppenspiel gab es gegen
frankreich einen last second sieg
punktlandung für die deutsche mannschaft
im letzten gruppenspiel martin häner
gelingt mit der schlusssirene
der siegtreffer zum 6 zu 5 der das team
von kais al saadi ins halbfinale bringt
abschluss einer furiosen aufholjagd zu
viel zu leichte gegentore in der ersten
halbzeit die das 52 der franzose kurz
abgefälscht foto ta die florian fuchs
war mit beginn der zweiten halbzeit der
anschlusstreffer gelungen deutschland
die letzten fünf minuten ohne torhüter
mit einem weiteren feldspieler und fürs
risiko belohnt und morgan spielen die
deutschen auch die frauen um den einzug
ins halbfinale
drückt mir die daumen und schauen jetzt
noch auf eines der größten lebewesen das
jemals auf der erde lebte mitten im
australischen nirgendwo hatten farmer
vor 15 jahren erste knochen gefunden
jetzt ist klar was da in staubiger erde
schlummert eine neue saurier art 30
meter lang sechseinhalb meter hoch der
größte australier aller zeiten lebte wo
95 millionen jahren
aktuell gibt es unwetterwarnungen in
einem streifen von sachsen anhalt bis
bayern morgen wird's für die einen
wieder sonnig und warm für die anderen
erst drückt und dann gewittrig mehr hat
gleich katja von claus kleber begrüßt
sie um viertel vor zehn heute journal
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen noch einen entspannten
dienstagabend bis morgen wenn sie mit
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren schon
seit tagen gibt es ganz wenig
veränderung bei unserem wetter da liegt
ein gewittertief ihr über den alpen und
ein weiteres nördlich vom schwarzen meer
diese wetterlage ist wie festgetackert
es ändert sich einfach ganz wenig und so
gab es auch in den vergangenen 24
stunden kräftige regenfälle und heftige
gewitter und das vor allen dingen in
bayern und in baden württemberg jetzt in
den vergangenen sechs stunden kamen auch
einige gewitter hier richtung thüringen
dazu und das ist die region in der es
jetzt am abend und auch in der nacht
kräftig gewittern wird also ungefähr
zwischen dem harz und dem schwarzwald
sie sehen das ganz schön auf unserer
nacht karte zum frühen morgen leben die
gewitter im thüringer wald und im
erzgebirge sogar wieder auf in der
feuchten luft bildet sich hier und da
auch mal etwas nebel und die
temperaturen sinken in dieser nacht auf
15 bis 9 grad und steigen dann morgen
über tag auf 20 bis maximal 27 grad in
der lausitz auch morgen ist es wieder in
norddeutschland sehr freundlich sondern
wolken wechseln sich ab im süden gibt es
schon die ersten regenschauer und
gewitter die wachsen sich am nachmittag
dann wieder zu wettern aus und in den
nächsten tagen ziehen sich die gewitter
nach südosten zurück veh nahm noch